pues avanzan muy lentamente con dados
importantes donde se centran la gran
votación de en Estados como Arizona y
Nevada avanzan lentamente de hecho en
Nevada los oficiales electorales esperan
recibir en los próximos días 300 cajas
más llenas de votos para empezar a
contarlas y teniendo en cuenta que los
márgenes entre los candidatos que están
pendientes por definirse a la cámara de
representantes son tan estrechos pues
estos votos podrían hacer la diferencia
un caso similar pasa en Arizona donde
pues llegaron hace muy pocas horas cerca
de 400.000 votos según oficiales
electorales de ese estado que van a
tener que empezar a contar y pues a
repartir entre demócratas y republicanos
esto tardará según oficiales electorales
estatales y analistas electorales a
nivel nacional pues días en conocerse
Pues esa balanza y conocerse Sí sí sí
qué tan rápido llega en cualquier
partido a esa cifra mágica en la cámara
de representantes que es la mayoría de
218 votos o la cifra de 50 votos 50
sillas escaños en el senado para lograr
la mayoría en la cámara alta y cómo le
fue en estas elecciones a los candidatos
de Trump y que desconocieron los
resultados pasados
por medios como el Washington como New
York Times dicen que Trump después de
conocer los resultados electorales
estaba muy molesto con sus candidatos
sin embargo la autocrítica que hacen
estos candidatos es que pues no
recibieron mucha financiación mucho
apoyo por parte del ex presidente Donald
Trump durante las campañas electorales y
que esto pues obviamente tuvo efecto en
que demócratas que no los conocían mucho
reversaran y tomar a los cargos de
republicanos que pues eran muy cercanos
a Donald Trump de hecho pues el
Washington dice que de las cerca de 300
candidatos que apoyaba Donald Trump que
además desconocían los resultados
electorales de las elecciones del 2020
solo 145 de los 300 que desconocían
estas elecciones del 2020 ganaron
escaños ganaron sus carreras electorales
en esta elección de medio término y sin
duda pues es un revés para el presidente
Donald Trump que tendrá Pues que empezar
a repensar como va a abordar su campaña
de reelección en el 2024